hey Theo this is Joey from Ventura a
question for genie from Lakers nation
when you posed for Playboy
ooh what did doctor bus think of that
anyway I love the show feel young gay
Wow
we can hit we believe we'll leave them
on for this part okay um yeah I haven't
seen too much can we bring these images
up or this can be really awkward
no you yeah let's bring a mug bro I mean
this seems like an a professional it
seemed like yeah and this could this is
gonna be part of my comedy looks I'd
like I could write and you know give you
some nice is perfect but you know
actually when I'm up in high def if you
don't mind brother see what they had and
you know I talked about challenging
myself to you know uh you know do things
that are jeannie bugs my comfort zone
and this was definitely one of those
things it was after my first marriage
ended and I decided okay what are some
of the things that I would do if I was
single and this was and so I went to I
had to I was like any other model who
was in the magazine I had to go to a
test photo shoot never told my dad about
it I went through all the you know test
photos and so a little disconcerting to
see the pictures as I'm talking about
and click through them a little bit
Nicki you don't mind so I can listen and
think at the same time yeah so I was
approved did the photo shoot then I told
my dad that it was coming out and my dad
so brilliant had the the greatest quote
ever which was it will be the first
issue of Playboy magazine I've never
read Wow
so he he endorses the magazine but he
you know I've insist on endorses his
daughter and seeing his daughter news
right and so you know and you know I
didn't know I didn't read playboy all
right you know and I didn't really
realize like how hairstyles
you know hairstyles change and
hairstyles change
oh yeah it's kind of Jeannie Bush a
little yeah that's exact on of the times
I remember some of these magazines and
stuff and you would see in the Tet just
had more of a natural kind of vibe to it
but so they didn't like did they tell
you you have to shave or anything no
they didn't tell me anything they you
know it was it was I thought like you
know I would I would you know the first
time that I would you know take oh so
nervous and I thought it was like this
is just gonna be like oh my god and like
nobody cared they're like doing their
work they're like fixing the light you
know and then there's a guy crying on
the phone to his wife just normal
activity right yeah it just it was like
what the only person who was hung up on
it was meet you who'd you take with you
to the shoot really yeah at what age is
this at Jeannie I was 32 when I did it
Wow and so what kind of 30 Tirol just
drop just me you know what's on my to-do
list today I have to hit the grocery I
have to check on a say see greens
virginity whoa second page of Google
Image Search no I you know it's funny
because when when the Lakers went to the
the White House when Obama was president
and you know I we all got to meet him in
the green room before we went out to do
the presentation and so I introduced
myself to him and he said I know who you
are
and I felt so like self-conscious like
he'd seen me in Playboy
do you think indeed is that the vibe you
got the colors that it was it's okay
he's the president deserves a look at
play well I and I do I have you know I
have you know people now that come up to
me and they said that you were the first
naked person I've ever seen you know and
and you know now mind you I did this in
the early 90s before the internet really
was right so yeah pictures are with me
forever and you know I so going back do
you think you would have kind of had a
dip
hairstyle you thinker doesn't matter
really yeah yeah I would have been more
like race racing strip or whatever yeah
something fancy clown ears or some
Disney ears when you look at these
pictures is it just kind of like oh do
you remember the day pretty fun like was
it just one day was it a couple no it
was the hardest work I've ever done
where I was so physically tired but
mentally completely not stimulated at
all like really like I it like where you
have to like stay put with an arch in
your back and you know yeah do not move
and it was I all my all the power to
models in the world because they don't
get enough credit for the kind of
physicality that is to pose do you feel
sexy looking at these pictures is it
feeling like that you know not yeah
kinda but I mean not at that time
because it's you're you're working was
your city did you have any siblings that
were jealous give us it was your sister
there were no jealousy like that no
sister jealousy no I mean me doing this
didn't preclude anybody else from doing
anything they would want to do that's a
good point you would you do it again you
know I'm really good friends with Cooper
Hefner you have no son and you know they
he's you know taking the magazine in a
different direction I'm so proud of him
at his young age he's really shown the
kind of thoughtfulness and you know
really you know really wants the
magazine to stand for something
important and everybody should follow
him on Instagram because he's really
he's a really special kid and of this
generation that generation and so I
don't think they would ask me a kid but
if they asked do you think he was awed
by an issue to sold one issue thank you
so - Wow and Nick could have borrowed
mine but let's t be honest he wants his
own
for what reasons who knows but obviously
does want to borrow his buddies so
that's two issues there we go Cooper so
what do you think so you're saying
there's a chance